it's great to be joined today by Liz
suave Ola who is a senior program
associate at the Vera Institute of
justice and also one of the authors of
the recent report overlooked women in
jails in an era of reform Liz it's so
great to talk to you you know but
prisons and jails are often considered a
sort of men's issue the so-called men's
rights movement often talks about it in
that context but you studied another
angle of incarceration in the u.s. which
is that we've seen a 14 fold increase in
women in the correctional population
over the last just under 45 years what's
driving that increase let's start sort
of at the very top level the number of
women in jails that's local county
municipality run facilities and most of
those people are pretrial so they've
been arrested but they haven't been
convicted of anything they're weeding
the resolution of their cases and one
thing that was really surprising in our
research is that despite this dramatic
growth we don't still to this day know
what's really driving it because there
hasn't been much research specific to
women and what we were able to find in
our research about women in the colonel
justice system more generally is that
increasing focus on low-level nonviolent
offenses has really swept a large number
of women into the system and when we
talk about nonviolent offenses I mean I
think because of what we've experienced
within the war on drugs oftentimes
people's minds when they hear nonviolent
offenses they think of sort of drug use
for example possession etc but really
when we talk about nonviolent offenses
it includes more than just that doesn't
it I mean talk to us about some of the
other nonviolent offenses that are
landing people in jail in prison I'm so
not sales specifically for women and its
property offenses
Public Order offenses things like
loitering disorderly conduct I'm so
we're talking about really minor
low-level crimes talk to us a little bit
about the dynamic in terms of how the
criminal justice system sort of accounts
for the the reality that in the u.s.
women are more likely mothers are more
likely to be the caregivers for children
than our fathers and sort of how that is
impacting and influencing that the
numbers that we're seeing in terms of
female incarceration doesn't account for
that dynamic unfortunately about 80
percent of women in jails are mothers
oftentimes they are single mothers and
quite frequently when they are ending up
in the criminal justice system it's
related to efforts to kind of survive so
as we said it's property crimes it can
relate to mental health and behavioral
health and when they're coming into the
system that impacts their entire
families especially their children
visiting can be very difficult even
staying in touch by phone can be
prohibitively expensive many of these
families are poor and low-income and it
can be very difficult for for mother and
child to stay in touch when we think
about the incarceration of mothers
there's sort of this vicious cycle that
can develop where we know that a child
who has one or two parents that have
been in the system are those children
are more likely later on to end up in
the system themselves and there's this
this sort of vicious cycle that I've not
really heard a particularly good
explanation as to how it can be broken
but let me open up sort of that topic to
you first
talk a little bit about that right the
impact that the incarceration of mothers
has on the children and and whether you
want to talk short medium and law or
long term whichever way you want to go
with it
parent especially mother is incarcerated
there can be a whole host of
consequences I mean very from the very
first point of arrest that can be
incredibly traumatic for children that
can result in nightmares and stress and
trouble at school you know it's still an
area of emerging research really what
the long-term consequences are but
incarceration of children who have
parents who are incarcerated has been
you know strongly correlated we know
from having spoken to so many experts
around these issues that when someone is
incarcerated they're often to say
rehabilitated is very very far from the
truth they often come out of jail or
prison actually more disadvantaged less
likely to ultimately find stable
employment etc we know that generally
does your report tell us anything more
specifically about how that dynamic the
sort of furthering of the disadvantage
is affecting women who are incarcerated
absolutely they're really experiencing a
whole system with policies and practices
that are designed for men and that
really does please leave them worse off
than when they came into jail it can be
anything as basic as hygiene so having
access to feminine hygiene products
having access to toilet paper through to
trauma I mean the experience can be
incredibly traumatizing for women many
of whom have already experienced trauma
in their lifetime nearly 90 percent have
experienced sexual violence over the
course of their lifetime so when they
come to jail and they are searched or
shackled or held in solitary confinement
a lot of that trauma is read triggered
and it can really leave them worse off
as well as financial consequences many
women coming to jail are more
disadvantaged even than their male
counterparts so about 60% of women who
are in jail were unemployed before they
came to jail
and so when they
leaving jail and they have all of these
fines and fees that really rack up in
every single point of the criminal
justice process they are even further
economically disadvantaged this sort of
gets us to one of the the chicken-egg
discussions that often exists in these
conversations and I'll focus on the
unemployment aspect of it because you
brought it up some might hear this
scenario right they said they hear you
say incarceration rate of women has gone
up so significantly we also see 60% of
women coming into the system are
unemployed so we should really be
looking at arresting women less or
changing laws in order to reduce the
number of women arrested to begin with
others will hear it and they'll say well
the problem is really jobs right if we
were able to grow employment and make it
so that more women were employed and
addressed the issues that exists there
that's just going to naturally reduce
the number of women who end up in
situations where they end up getting
arrested is either of these approaches
does it does one or the other approach
make more sense to you is it parts of
both is it something else altogether is
really a result of poverty but also
increasingly becoming a cause of poverty
we have to look at the very beginning of
the system at arrests to think about
means that women can be diverted away
from the criminal justice system so that
they can engage in employment and
education treatment they can stay with
their families and maintain their
housing and think about you know every
step of the process you know those
opportunities to divert women away and
to also reinvest in our communities
instead of in incarceration to allow for
for more opportunities in the community
in so many of the communities that we
work with here at Avira Institute
very large amounts of
our budget goes towards incarcerating
people and you know I think we feel that
that that those resources would be
better spent creating more opportunities
in the community now Liz there will be
some who hear our conversation and
they'll say I agree with everything that
liz is saying we do need to be focusing
on all of those areas in order to reduce
female incarceration but shouldn't it
really apply to both men and women in
other words why is it that or not why is
it but do you feel that there is a
particular need to focus on reducing
female incarceration as a result of
certain types of crimes or economic
situations or whatever or are you sort
of merely pointing out that is it it has
increased more rapidly than male
incarceration but really we should be
making sure that we're treating
everybody in the same way and and I
asked this sort of because I know many
in the audience will hear our
conversation and that's the first
question I'll get percentage but they
are in jail and we are in this moment of
reform where local communities are
rethinking the way that they use their
jails and we absolutely encourage that
for all people both men and women there
should be opportunities to stay in the
community we're also being held
accountable but what we're seeing is
that as reforms are coming up and new
innovations are created such as
diversion programs they're not always
focusing on women and therefore aren't
reaching as women to the extent that
they're really reaching men so it's
important that we have conversations
overall about reducing the use of jails
but there there also be a specific focus
on women to make sure that any more
forms that are created are reaching them
and providing them opportunities as well
last issue I want to touch on if we had
to point to one specific law enforcement
initiative whose change might have the
the biggest impact do you come to war on
drugs and the status quo
there you know I think there are many
different factors I think the war on
drugs has certainly contributed
significantly to the number of women in
jails
I think communities are increasingly
just relying on their jails to provide
services that should be provided by the
community behavioral health mental
health substance use treatment there's
really you know the jails are the mental
health providers of last resort and we
need to rethink that and make sure that
resources are available in the community
to prevent people from ending up in jail
we've been speaking with Liz Savola
senior program associate at the Vera
Institute of Justice the report is
called overlooked women in jails in an
era of reform Alice thanks so much for
talking to us about this it's even my
pleasure